the Joe Rogan experience mr. Shermer how
are you sir
I'm fine thank you I'm still breathing
it's good to see you again we were just
saying before we got started that the
last time we saw each other was we went
to dinner about six weeks ago and you're
thinking that that might be the end of
that kind of stuff that was my last time
I've been in a restaurant actually and
well I you know I think restaurants of
course will reopen but I think the kind
of social distancing we're seeing now
it's not gonna go all the way back to
the way it used to be I think we may
quit shaking hands and hugging to the
extent that we used to although I don't
think we'll ever ever go all the way to
the say the Japanese model of social
distancing but I think there'll be
modifications like that the other thing
I've been thinking about is the change
of remote say meetings and education I
mean I'm in the studio here in Santa
Barbara where I've been recording
lectures for my Chapman University class
skepticism 101 and I just upload them
and share them with the students and and
then they watch them and then I send
them a quiz they take the quiz they send
them back now that's not a complete
replacement of a brick and mortar
building with a small class seminar
discussion say but but it does you know
not adequately replace a lot of
traditional education that you don't
really need to be in a classroom for do
you think that this is preparing us for
the ultimate where we embrace the
symbiotic relationship that we have with
computers and become one with the
machine I mean it seems like work yeah
we're coming closer and closer to some
sort of an electronic community it's
weird yeah I think was I think it was
happening slowly already and this is
kind of a jump starting it I mean
already tech companies like zoom or
having to you know ramp up their game
because you know the systems are
crashing because pretty much everybody's
doing zoom meetings now yeah and then
they have to it and they have to adjust
the zoom bombing because of Moore's
there's you know people like that out
there they just want to screw with you
and so I and then I was also thinking
about things like theatres you know -
what why do we need to go to theaters
anymore I mean I love watching a movie
on a big screen but you know the the
screens we have at home now big
television screens super high-def you
know why not just watch movies at all
I don't think we're gonna have much of a
choice I was reading an article this
morning about AMC Theaters might they
might have to go under because of this
really yeah that's not good I mean you
got to think these companies are
accustomed to having a certain amount of
money coming in every month and they
never no one anticipated anything like
this we're all businesses are just gonna
shut down gyms I mean how many gyms are
gonna go under how many yoga studios
many I mean it's a it's a strange and
trying time for people who have small
businesses for sure yeah one of my
cycling buddies owns the LA cañada
theater complex and and of course rents
out the space to different retailers
including the theater theater managers
and anyway he was telling me that you
know they normally pay ninety three
thousand dollars a month in rent but you
know they bring in like seven and a half
million dollars a year or something so
it all balances out but they just told
him we're not gonna make our rent this
month so he has to go to his mortgage
company you know the bank they where he
gets paid off his mortgage and so I
can't pay you this month because these
guys can't pay me and okay so multiply
that by you know 10 million or 100
million or something and that's kind of
what we've been going through yeah and I
don't really understand the economics of
this stimulus package of how they're
going to be able to distribute it and
sort of balance people out it seems like
it's just a small band-aid on a very
large wound yeah well of course the
government can't just print money right
indefinite indefinitely then we're gonna
get huge inflation and then and that
could be catastrophic you know so this
conversation that people have been
wanting to have but they get hammered
every time they bring it up I think at
some point we're gonna have to have in
the next few weeks is the economic
trade-off and costs to people's lives
compared to what we're doing with social
social isolation to save people's lives
yeah and at the at the moment we're in
the mode of there's no dollar amount you
could put on a human life there for
total social isolation no matter what
does to the economy is what we're gonna
do now well but at some point you know
you know there's a economic calculation
like how many people are gonna die say
in the next year if we never open the
economy of course we will but you know
at what point do you do that you know
the supply chain dries up you can't get
not just toilet paper but you know food
supplies start to dry
and then you get social unrest and you
know there's risks there too you know
yeah and the idea of putting a dollar
figure on a human life is repulsive to
most of us I think intuitively in this
context but in fact we do it all the
time you know in terms of like an
automobile company has to pay off the
family of somebody who died in their car
well there are people who do those
calculations like what's the value of a
human life and the figure is well the
high-end figure is about ten million
dollars now after 9/11 the families got
paid off I think it was two hundred
fifty thousand dollars a person times
the three thousand something and you
know so it sounds so cold like who does
those calculations well statisticians do
that sort of thing and attorneys and
accountants work on that and judges and
juries have to face it and you know
that's kind of a normal part of other
aspects of life that we're not used to
thinking about most of us don't think
about it but you know at some point
that's the kind of calculation we're
gonna have to do for what we're in now
[Applause]